dans la cour des invalides des candidats
à l'élection présidentielle tous bords
confondus sont venus rendre hommage aux
harkis
car je reconnais les responsabilités des
gouvernements français dans l'abandon
des harkis des massacres de ceux restés
en algérie et des conditions d'accueil
inhumaines des familles transférées dans
les camps en france une tâche de 101 db
aidé les bills reste sur le drapeau
tricolore par ian deuxième étape c'est
la mise en place de mesures d'insertion
économique et professionnelle et puis
peut être accordé la légion d'honneur à
l'ensemble des harkis qui restent vives
en fin de la cérémonie et des poignées
de main
observer à quelques mois de la
présidentielle henry vous avez déclaré
je suis sûr que nicolas sarkozy est
honnête vous pouvez leur dire sans rire
perdu le président du modem a bien du
mal à se faire entendre dans le paysage
politique et craint d'être asphyxié par
cet homme
emmanuel macron qui pourrait lui
disputer le petit espace du centre en
5min km devrait marche il ya eu le
moindre effet magnétique que macron en
50 mètres devant une caméra alors
comment faire pour faire parler de ce
mouvement il est meilleur que moi nos
écrans à l'écouter il a lu chez chez
rothschild il a fait l'école comme je
n'ai pas une approche de fonds de
commerce ou de paysages mort de la vie
politique
et puis je sais pas pourquoi toutes les
caméras à l'école au plus moins que toi
emmanuel macron fait un pas de plus vers
2017 il est ce week-end l'invité du
sommet des réformistes européens
organisés à lyon depuis le lancement des
invitations emmanuel macron a
démissionné de son poste et beaucoup de
participants qui se sont désistés comme
pierre moscovici ou encore le think tank
de gauche terra nova
je trouve que c'est toujours dommage
quand on a quelque chose à dire de ne
pas venir l'échangé il ya une
interprétation qui peut être qu'on n'a
plus grand chose à dire les pressions
traduisent une fébrilité donc demandé
aux fébrile nous ne sommes pas pris à
une phrase de régis debray que j'aime et
que je suis sûr vous aimez l'homme
d'état est celui qui veut les
conséquences de ce qu'il veut
voilà absolument il ça c'est autre chose
que les pieds rigolo qu'on a rien depuis
dix ans ils veulent pas mon problème
c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas laisser pour
ça qu'ils assument jamais ils ne veulent
pas les conséquences de ce qu'ils valent
d'ailleurs veulent t'ils quelque chose
la plupart du temps non à part gagner
les élections et être pouvoir et dire
après on verra bien
je ne ferai pas campagne pour valls je
ne ferai pas campagne pour macron je ne
ferai pas campagne pour monsieur
hollande c'est eux qui se sont comptées
lmnp dégoûter tout le monde qu'ils ont
fini par faire fuir les électeurs